with great power comes great box office
returns oh yeah
I can't help but think that there was a
Sony executive somewhere who said those
exhaust exact words in a meeting so
first trailer dropped for a spider-man
far from home now before I get into
talking about this specifically I will
remind you I really like spider-man
homecoming like a lot like I don't it's
still closed between that into the
spider verse in spider-man 2 as to which
is my favorite spider-man movie it's
really neck and neck between all three I
really enjoyed it I loved the villain I
thought Tom Holland was great I think
the little shifts and changes that they
made and the way that it was presented
was all really well done the arc that
they did with Peter especially with his
relationship with Tony was awesome so
yeah I've been excited for this for this
sequel to come out now having seen the
trailer I'm still excited but I'm also a
little nervous and like for reasons that
I'm a little conflicted over I'll do my
best to try and explain so first off I
actually basically saw two trailers
because both the domestic and the
international trailer job today and had
slightly different stuff mostly at the
front end it's a question of whether it
opened with a with an airport luggage
check you know checking the contents of
the bag joke or hinting at how
uncomfortable Peter is at seeing Aunt
May kind of flirt with with happy Hogan
joke but by and large all still touching
on the same stuff so we've got Peter now
in Europe being contacted by Nick Fury
he's trying to get something you know
started with MJ hoot God she's got great
lines I really I really do enjoy Zen die
in this part like a lot I love him going
you're pretty she goes and therefore I
have value to you and he gets also
consciousness I'm just messing with you
dude
I really enjoy the heck out of her I
mean Ned you know being all excited and
and into things and a few glimpses at
some of the struggles and villainous
sort of stuff going on and I'll kind of
come back to that the first thing I want
to talk about is like the whole sort of
central concept of spider-man on a
school trip to another country and I
have kind of mixed feelings about it
because on the one hand it feels like it
feels like a very obvious you know just
page out of the sequel choices book
guide that doesn't exist but I don't
know like well let's take them to a
different location just seems like a
very bog-standard
way to do a sequel you know and and has
been for a long time okay kind of has
that feel to it but at the same time
it's the kind of plot that would have
been done to shake things up in like the
old spider-man comics like 60s and 70s
Dracula Stanley was actually writing
this thing you know it had that that
that was the kind of thing they do to
freshen it up a little bit every now and
then and I kind of and in it and it's a
smaller way to freshen it up as opposed
to going bigger stakes and like having
him dealing with you know city or
world-threatening stuff and because one
of the things I really liked about
homecoming was the emphasis on friendly
neighborhood spider-man he was dealing
with a smaller threat he was he was in a
smaller story a story about on scale
with what the classic spider-man stories
were because spider-man doesn't save the
city he stops
bank robbers with gimmicks it's it's one
of the things I like about him and you
know I liked seeing that embraced in
last one and I will admit that this
concept kind of gels with that entire
mentality and sort of that vibe of the
of that era of spread when comics that
homecoming pulled from so as much as I'm
kind of like going Europe trip it feels
like a little cheesy a little obvious I
also can sort of think yeah but maybe
it's kind of fitting anyway so I I would
say that's not an automatic like me
going good but I'm like I'm skeptical
but can also kind of see how maybe that
could work bringing in Nick Fury is an
interesting choice I'm not entirely sure
what to make of that it's obviously
can't be the same kind of relationship
that Peter had with Tony I have to
wonder if part of the reason for this is
if they just didn't want to shell out
for Robert Downey jr. to come back and
be in this again and so they want with
with Sam Jackson instead um I don't know
that's speculation on my part but it
doesn't feel quite as organic but again
it will depend on the situation and and
how things actually pan out you know the
little moments of ty I mean Tom Hollands
so adorable as Peter so lots of little
moments little looks little who's like
nervous and everything I really do like
I really do like him in this part but
let's get to the bit of the new
character that we see and some of the
hints of the threat and whatnot now
depending on what you know about the
comics some of what I'm gonna talk about
in relation to the character who we see
who's called Mysterio in this might
constitute spoilers for someone who does
not know this character or know the
comics very well at all so if you want
to go if you don't have that background
knowledge and you want to be surprised
you maybe need to check out of the video
about now
but I mean if you
anything about Mysterio at all you'll
get what I'm what I'm about to say here
but just wanted to get fair warning so
the it there's some interesting sort of
little bits in that in this because
we've sort of got like these big
monstery looking things one looks like
it's made of dirt it's kind of Sandman
reminiscent another ones made out of
water it seems to have a hydro man thing
going on and then Mysterio played by
Jake Gyllenhaal shows up on a nowhere
and starts battling them now because of
Mysterio's deal which is that he deals
in illusion and trickery and just
creating fake nests my presumption is
that this that these threats are things
that he set up so that he could then
defeat and appear to be hero to what
ultimate and I don't know that would be
my guess
given given his standard nature and sort
of template of what he does now here's
the big thing about Mysterio as a
villain in general I'm not a huge
Mysterio fan it's not cuz he's not a
good character but I feel that
ultimately he really only works as a
surprise villain where you find out as a
twist that he was behind stuff because
if you know the guy's deal at all ie
that it's all fake once you see him at
the start of something you know you know
exactly what's going on his but his
powers do lend him to be like the
surprise reveal because you know maybe
the hero is dealing with something else
then all of a sudden oh wait it wasn't
that it was Mysterio all along he's good
for that because it fits his gimmick but
you know III wonder how straight they're
gonna play that I mean to be fair they
did some pretty good work messing around
with the tinkerer and the vulture in the
previous one and all
during the characters to better fit the
story and the themes that they were
dealing with so I'm gonna have to kind
of trust that they're gonna do that
little Mysterio but I've kind of always
been skeptical about Mysterio as a
villain for the movies because I don't
know I don't know how you utilize him in
a movie in a way that isn't wasting the
time of the comics fans who already know
his deal because you can only surprise
the people who don't read the comics and
anyone who has or even does a quick
Wikipedia search you're going oh I
wonder what this new villain in the
spider-man movies like is gonna find out
at me the Oh master of illusion so I'm
hoping that they are aware enough to
really keep an eye on that and to
account for it and that they've come up
with a story and a plot and everything
else that that is not going to be
undermined by that fact and ideally
we'll somehow play with it I don't know
we'll see but yeah that III definitely
saw plenty of the bits that I'm like oh
man I really did love all that I'm and
you know reminding me of that stuff from
the first one but I'm slightly skeptical
of the overall concept of Spider Man you
know in Europe I'm actually fairly
skeptical of this villain and since we
only got basically a glimpse of him here
that wasn't enough for you know to for
me to be like oh yeah he'll be fine
hey baby he will be fine I just don't
know yet so those are my thoughts on the
trailer drops for spider-man far from
home you seen it what do you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it no idea why I rolled my R
on that whole bunch of buttons and links
down there including one to the patreon
if you feel like supporting me that way
every little bit
in fact help but there's other stuff
down there besides uh my p.o box and
other links to other things press them
they take you places or you know don't
if you don't feel like it that is
totally fine because at the end of the
day you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]